Could you speculate a little bit about how a company like Facebook
could use information about things like users clicking on a like button on something
to suggest possibly people to be friends with?
[Tina] Right. A simple way is this idea that --
Let's assume we have Mary, John, and Jill.
And Mary is friends with John and Jill, but John and Jill are not friends with each other.
Every time Mary posts something, both John and Jill like it.
So, because they keep liking the things that Mary posts,
we think, wow, they should like each other as well and want to be friends.
In fact, another reason that it makes sense to have them be friends
is that they're both friends with Mary,
and so they share a common friend and they like a lot of the stuff that Mary is posting.
So, that would be a good friend suggestion.
The more friends they have in common, the higher this idea
of, oh, they would want to be friends, because they share a lot of common friends.
This is a whole area called tie strength
about how strongly am I tied to you or would I be tied to you?
We actually recently had a paper at a web science conference on this.
When I actually go out of my way and like something,
it means that--and you go out of your way and like it--
it means that maybe we should be friends, because we like the same kinds of things.
It's also connected to the concept of homophily--
this idea of like attracting like.
It's been around in history for a very long time.
In fact, it dates all the way back to Plato,
which says similarity begets friendship.
Or for example in more common day we say "Birds of a feather flock together."
In a social network, links tend to connect people who are similar to one another.
So, I'm similar to you and so I would like to be your friend,
and so I have a link to you.
If, for example, you want to find out about whether I'm a good guy or a bad guy,
you can look at my friends and see if the majority of them are good guys or bad guys.
If the majority of them are good guys, then you would guess, well, Tina must be a good guy,
because she's friends with a lot of good guys.
And that's where also this idea of egonets comes along.
An egonet is a term in sociology,
and it refers to the ego.
And then I have my alters, which are my friends.
So, my friends are my alters, and the person you're considering is called the "ego."
The egonet is the network that connects the ego to the alters
and that connects the alters together.
You can have egonets that look like a star where you have the ego and the alters,
but none of the alters know each other.
Or you can have a clique where everybody knows each other in this egonet.
The ego obviously knows all the alters and is friends with all the alters
and all the alters are friends with each other.
In fact, going back to this idea of recommending links,
the closer--the more cliquey--your egonet is,
the more links there are in your egonet,
the more likely it is that the alters that aren't connected with each other
would want to be connected to each other.
Now, we looked at something in the class called the clustering coefficient.
Is it safe to define that as the density of the connections among your alters?
Or, if you want to think about it, the number of triangles that exist, right?, in your egonet.
Selection is the tendency of people to form friendship with others who are like them.
If you wanted to target an outreach for a particular product,
you're assuming that there is selection going on.
Influence is the fact that we're already friends,
and people may change their behavior to bring them more closely
into alignment with their friends.
That's where, for example, a lot of viral marketing is good for.
If you're trying to push something where the underlying cause is social influence,
then you would want to go with viral marketing.
So, with selection the individual characteristics drive the formation of friendship links,
and then with influence is the existing links in the networks to people's characteristics.
So, I buy iPhone and really like it. I play with it.
That influences you to go buy an iPhone.
Usually when people talk about influence they also talk about contagion.
It's basically the same kind of term.
People use it interchangeably.
There was this very famous study back in 2007 that got a lot of publicity
that was done by Professor Christakis at Harvard
and Professor Fowler at University of California, San Diego,
and they looked at how obesity is caused by influence,
that obesity is contagious.
They have this thing where having an obese friend increases your chance
of obesity by 57%.
That was when it got like everything was contagion.
Happiness was contagious, everything was contagious.
There's all these--like Time magazine had a front cover,
and Wired magazine and all that.
Then when people looked more into the model they found that, well,
wait a second.
If I follow the model, then tallness is also contagious.
Unfortunately, it's not, because I would like to be taller, but I'm not.
It really gets down to this idea of correlation and causation.
Lots and lots of interesting work with real applications.
Like if I have a product that I want to spread through a network
or if I want people to change their behavior and stop smoking,
is it influence or is it selection?
Because depending on which one it is, I should do either viral marketing or targeted outreach.
So, it's very important.